how many work visas were issued to
foreign Nationals last year
the most the the most recent the most
recent statistics we have to the most
recent history we had as the ons said at
the time contained a set of unique
circumstances including welcoming many
people here for humanitarian reasons
the figures are out it's a quarter of a
million work visas were issued last year
he knows that answer he just doesn't
want to give it
numbers tomorrow
expected to be even higher the Prime
Minister stood on three Tory manifestos
each one promised to reduce immigration
each promise broken they all stood on
those manifestos as well
it is his thing his Home Secretary
I've got aware of this question those
who don't want to hear it we know the
answer is Dharma they all
stood on those manifestos so why does he
think his Home Secretary seems to have
such a problem coping with points-based
systems
well
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
and the same respect will be sure the
prime minister
Mr Speaker just this week we announced
the biggest ever single measure to
tackle legal migration removing the
right for international students to
bring dependents toughening the rules on
post-study work and reviewing
maintenance requirements but what is the
honorable gentleman's contribution there
are absolutely no ideas
there is no no
no no absolutely no I did absolutely no
semblance that there would be any
control why because he believes in an
Open Door migration policy
speaker if anyone wants to see what
uncontrolled immigration looks like all
they've got to do is wake up tomorrow
morning listen to the headlines and see
what this government ordered Miss
Bristol I think you're going to be
leaving
I'm asking you to leave no because
otherwise I'll name it
and I've warned you before it's the same
people
[Applause]
[Music]
good summer Mr Speaker the reason
they're issuing so many visas is labor
and skill shortages and the reasons
there are shortages is the low wage Tory
economy under his government's rules
businesses in I.T engineering Healthcare
architecture welding can pay foreign
workers 20 percent less than British
workers for years and years on end does
he think his policy is encouraging
businesses to train people here or hire
from abroad
Minister Mr Speaker talks about
immigration but we know his position
because it turns out that labor would
actually like to see even more people
coming to the UK increasing the numbers
that's not just my view Mr Speaker those
were the words of his own from Venture
who said having a Target isn't sensible
and that the numbers might have to go up
Mr Speaker so it's clear whilst we're
getting on with clamping down on legal
migration listening to the British
public he's perfectly comfortable
wanting to say that he wants free
movement back
[Music]
Mr Speaker they've lost control of the
economy they've lost control of public
services and now they've lost control of
immigration and if he was serious about
weaning his government off the
immigration lever he would get serious
about wages in Britain and get serious
about skills and training the
apprenticeship Levy isn't working it's
hard to find a single business that
thinks that it is and the proof is that
almost half the levy isn't even being
spent that's fewer young people getting
the opportunities they need to fulfill
their potential businesses are trying
out for more flexibility in the levy so
they can train up their staff labor
would give them that
why won't he
Mr Speaker it's it's right that we're
talking about education
what he failed to mention
Ed in the past week what did we discover
thanks to the reforms of the
conservative government our young people
are now the best readers in the western
world
[Applause]
buy the party opposite he also he also
talked about our record on the economy
and I am very surprised Mr Speaker
because I've stood here week after week
when he's been so Keen to quote the IMF
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
he seemed to have missed their press
conference yesterday where they actually
said they actually raised our growth
forecast by one of the highest they've
ever done said that we've acted
decisively to make sure that the economy
is growing and credited this government
with having a very positive effect on
future growth
[Applause]
is the prime minister seriously
suggesting that breaking the economy
breaking Public Services losing control
of immigration there's some sort of fair
carefully crafted plan his policies are
holding working people back and all the
offers is more of the same but fear not
because speeding into the void left by
the Prime Minister comes the Home
Secretary
not with a plan for skills growth or
wages no her big idea is for British
workers to become fruit Pickers just in
case I can hardly believe she said this
that they forget how to do things
just the Prime Minister support this let
them pick fruit ambition for Britain or
does he wish he had the strength to give
her a career change of her own
foreign
service he talks about the economy again
I think he's just failed to know what
notice what's going on the IMF as
they've said the IMs have they said it's
right here Mr Speaker our forecast which
he was very keen to point out just a few
months ago now their forecasts are that
we will have stronger growth than
Germany France and Italy Mr Speaker what
do they say they're saying that we are
prioritizing what's right for the
British people Mr Speaker he talked
about public services I said best
reading results in the Western World
when it comes to the NHS what have we
just discover last week ambulance
waiting times at the fastest response in
two years Mr Speaker that's a
conservative government delivering for
the British people
Mr Speaker the Home Secretary may need a
speed awareness course he needs a
reality check
it's mess on immigration reveals a Tory
party with no ambition
Al and
and just the same old failed ideas low
wages and high tax labor would fix the
apprenticeship Levy fill the skills Gap
and stop businesses from recruiting from
abroad if they don't pay properly that's
because we're the party of working
people
say about him and his party that they
won't do the same
Mr Speaker
to speak any of these things Mr Speaker
and look that's the difference between
us Mr Speaker because every week we we
hear we hear a lot of empty rhetoric
from The Honorable gentleman opposite
but in the past week we can measure
ourselves by actions what have we done
on this side of the house we've
introduced new powers to curb disruptive
protests we
he's voted against every single one of
those and that's the difference between
us well he's working on the politics
we're working for the British people
thank you Mr Speaker we have all
witnessed how Putin is carrying out his
Savage war against Ukraine he commenced
it he is the aggressor and he cannot be
allowed to win that war is now at a
pivotal point so will the Prime Minister
use his friendship with president
zielinski to ensure whatever military
equipment they need they will get be
that missiles drones or jets oh